MICHAEL TRACY, I APPRECIATE YOUR
REPORTING ALWAYS.
THANK YOU.
SO WE SHOULD TELL YOU, AS WE SET
OUT THE TOP, THIS IS THE ONLY
OUR OWN AMERICAN TELEVISION THAT
IS NOT BROADCASTING UNFILTERED
PROPAGANDA INTO THE HOMES OF
UNSUSPECTING VIEWERS.
ON THE SCREEN YOU SEE A BOX IS
COME DIFFERENT TV CHANNELS
TAKING THE NANCY PELOSI
FEED UNFILTERED.
IF AT ANY TIME IN YOUR LIFE
YOU'VE EVER MADE FUN OF
TOTALITARIAN REGIMES THAT
BROADCAST LIES INTO THE HOMES OF
THE POPULATIONS THEY CAN'T TURN
OFF, TAKE A LOOK AT THAT.
THAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
MEANWHILE, GAS IS OVER FIVE
BUCKS.
INFLATION IS HIGHER THAN IT'S
BEEN IN THE LIFETIME OF MOST
AMERICANS.
VIOLENT CRIME IS MAKING CITIES
IMPOSSIBLE TO LIVE IN AND MORE
THAN HUNDRED THOUSAND AMERICANS
O.D.ED ON DRUGS LAST YEAR.
WHY ISN'T THERE PRIME TIME
HEARING ON THAT?
CHARLIE HURT IS THE OPINION
EDITOR OF
"THE WASHINGTON TIMES."
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
IF YOU TAKE US BACK WHAT WE ARE
REALLY WATCHING HIS MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS TALKING ABOUT
THEMSELVES AGAIN.
>> ABSOLUTELY, BECAUSE THE
ALTERNATIVE IS FOR THEM TO HAVE
TO TALK ABOUT POLICIES AND IF
THEY TALK ABOUT POLICIES THEY
HAVE TO TALK ABOUT -- IT'S NOT
JUST ALL THE FAILURES WE SEE IN
FRONT OF US.
GAS PRICES, CRIME, OPEN BORDER,
FENTINYL DEATHS.
THEY WILL FIND OUT THAT
AMERICANS ARE VERY, VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT A LOT OF THEM.
THIS IS NOT ONE OF THEM BUT THEN
HE STEPPED BACK EVEN FARTHER AND
YOU LOOK AT THE CAVALCADE OF
LIES THAT DEMOCRAT POLITICIANS
HAVE MADE IN THEIR PROMISES TO
GET ELECTED.
EVEN BEFORE JOE BIDEN CAME TO
WASHINGTON.
WHETHER IT IS HELPING
HEALTH CARE PROBLEMS FOR POOR
PEOPLE, ENDING POVERTY OR
PROVIDING PUBLIC EDUCATION FOR
PEOPLE, THEY FAILED ON ALL OF
THESE FRONTS AND THE REASON, I
CALL THIS THE THIRD FAILED
IMPEACHMENT TRIAL OF
DONALD J. TRUMP YOU'RE THE
REASON THEY HAVE TO TALK ABOUT
THIS STUFF IS BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
TALK ABOUT OTHER ISSUES, THEY
HAVE TO DISTRACT EVERYBODY.
BUT THEN IT IS EVEN CRAZIER THAN
THAT BECAUSE WHEN YOU GET TO THE
ISSUE OF SECURITY AND YOU THINK
ABOUT PEOPLE WHOSE BUSINESSES
HAVE BEEN DESTROYED IN THESE
RIOTS RUNNING UP TO THE
ELECTION.
THINK ABOUT THE PARENTS, THEY
FEAR FOR THEIR CHILDREN GOING
INTO AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL TODAY
AND DEMOCRATS CONTROL BOTH
CHAMBERS OF CONGRESS AND THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THEY HAVE NOT DONE A DAMN THING
TO PROTECT CHILDREN IN SCHOOLS.
BEYOND THAT, THE THIRD BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT, THE JUDICIARY.
WE HAVE SUPREME COURT JUSTICES
LIVING UNDER THE THREAT OF THEIR
FAMILY BEING ASSASSINATED.
AND NANCY PELOSI WILL DO NOTHING
ABOUT IT.
ALL SHE CAN TALK ABOUT IS THIS
DAY A YEAR AND A HALF AGO WHEN
SHE WAS AFRAID, OR THEY WERE
AFRAID OF SOME GOOFBALL
TRESPASSING, NUTTY RIOTERS
COMING THROUGH THE CAPITAL?
I THINK WHAT WE ARE SEEING --
AND TO THINK ALL OF THIS IS
GOING TO BACKFIRE.
AND I THINK WHAT WE'RE SEEING
HEAR, HEAR, I THINK IT'S GREAT.
THE IMAGE YOU JUST SHOWED OF ALL
THE NETWORKS NETWORKS, OF
OBEDIENT PEOPLE, OBEDIENT
NETWORK SHOWING THIS THING ON
COMMAND.
I THINK WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS THE
FINAL SWIRLING OF CREDIBILITY
FOR THE MEDIA AND DEMOCRATS ARE
GOING DOWN DRAIN.
I THINK THEY ARE GOING TO PAY A
PRICE AND I THINK THIS SPECTACLE
RIGHT HERE IS GOING TO MAKE IT
EVEN WORSE FOR THEM, BECAUSE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THEIR CONCERN
HERE AND THE CONCERN ABOUT
ANYBODY ELSE, INCLUDING SCHOOL
CHILDREN IN ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS,
IT'S A BREATHTAKING.
>> Tucker: YOU AND I ENTERED
JOURNALISM ABOUT THE SAME TIME
30 YEARS AGO.
IT SEEMED HONORABLE THA